[Music]
good morning everyone
thanks for coming through session dat o2
who went to change smokers last night
all right one two all right how's your
hearing speak louder all right so we
have two sessions today I know you guys
have a choice of multiple sessions so as
a gift we have two sessions today one by
me I'm parvis day heem I'm a big this
big data specialist at Google and with
me I have Robin senior of director of
data engineering data science from
Tapjoy a bit of introduction on what I
do at Google I'm fortunate enough to
work with a variety of different
customers and it's exciting job I get to
work with so many different use cases so
many different customers and see what
they do on how they do stuff and it's
not a single day that I'm not surprised
on what customers do and what customers
don't do and how impressive the stuff
that they do with the stuff on where the
tools that we give them and Robin is
here to tell you about the journey that
he took from verdict on Prem Hadoop on
Prem moving it to bakery moving the data
and analytics to Hadoop running on
Google compute engine and few other
resources that he's using today so all
of our customers take the exciting
journey to get there and as I was like
writing this presentation it went back I
went back to the journey that I took
back in 2011 and that's when I started
working with variety of different tools
and big data products I don't know if
you guys remember Hadoop 0.2 spark 0.3
that's back then when spark was running
on mesas they didn't have its own
scheduler remember the days I used to
work with meant a to get stuff
troubleshoot it and then spark came
along start taking over hadoo kafka came
along and few other different tools came
along and the reason they all came along
was to satisfy
one goal that all of our customers have
been asking and they're asking today
which is reduced time to incite
customers want to get really fast inside
from their data and they want to get it
now it's not no longer acceptable to
wait for the batch of data to be
processed from wait for a day wait for a
week even so that's not acceptable
anymore and I'm starting to see the
paradigm of people moving from bash to
streaming and it's it's been interesting
actually some people are still in steam
batch some people are still doing some
stuff part of it doing streaming and
what I found there are more looking with
customers is that simply moving to
streaming analytics doesn't make your
infrastructure quicker doesn't give you
ability to get insight from your data
quicker what customers have to do on
what I found out from working with a
variety of different customers is that
they have to simplify they have to
sanitize and they have to optimize their
infrastructure and that's what I'm going
to talk to you guys about today it's a
very quick talk from me ten minutes and
I'll do my pitch and Robin is gonna come
and talk about their journey hopefully
this is clear enough for you guys to see
from here but this is typically if I
helps to summarize all the architecture
that I see for my customers everyone
that I talk to you this is a general
summarization of what customers do and
I'm using Google products here because I
love the Google products and it's a
Google conference but you can replace
these components with open-source
solutions for example oh sorry so pops
up you can replace that with Kafka or
Pasha Kafka or any other sort of ingest
tool dataflow spark flink they're all
open source solutions bigquery data
warehousing solution and you can replace
that with any anything else that you
like but the general theme is that
customers use some sort of real-time
data ingest tool like pops up or Kafka
they use some sort of distributed system
to take that data and put it into some
sort of data warehouse some other no
sequel databases or something else what
happens is that this is sort of a good
architecture but it's semi optimized
I don't know if you guys actually it's
obvious what's not optimized here you go
from streaming you're doing streaming
now but towards the end to start doing
some sort of cleaning aggregation
joining and doing discovery of data all
this stuff in red takes time takes times
takes a day like they wait for a day to
aggregate they wait for the to join data
joining data takes a long time so from
that perspective this is not a really
streaming architecture this is streaming
at ingest but all but still baffling in
a batch paradigm so throughout the stock
I'm just gonna unpack that talk about a
few things that you guys customers
should be able to do very high-level but
hopefully it's helpful to you guys one
of the first thing I want to talk about
is simplify your architecture as much as
you can use simple tools and simple
simple platforms it's tempting and it's
very valid to use spark dataflow Apache
being flanked all these different
distributed systems but it's common that
I talk to customers where all they do is
they take data and do some cleaning they
do some sanitization and if that's all
what you're doing you don't need to use
a distributed system it's okay to use it
but but distributive system you have to
maintain it you have to make sure it's
updated you have to make sure the bugs
are fixed you have to deal with
semantics of exactly one still over a
that at least one still array there's a
lot of complicated stuff that you have
to deal with but if all you're doing is
simple tasks it would be easy to use
something like cloud functions that is
event-driven architecture data comes in
event gets fired to cloud functions you
do something with it and gets put that
data in destination and in the sink or
wherever it needs to go it's simple a
server list you don't have to manage an
infrastructure you don't have to patch
anything you don't have to do DevOps or
anything else it's already taken care of
for you so very simple use simple point
of solutions something like cloud
functions or other things sanitize your
data early generally or very common what
I see is customers do cling of data when
data gets to destination that's fine and
it's much better than many other
architecture I've seen but if what
you're doing is cleaning try to do
cleaning and ingest
time try to do cleaning of data at the
cloud functions if using spark streaming
at spark flanked apology beam data flow
whatever do that cleaning early on in
the process most customers actually try
to do this under doing this so I think
this point should be simple to do the
other thing is schema validation what
customers do is they put data on
destination and they do discovery to
find data but what I like my customers
to do is they do schema validation and
schema registration much earlier in the
process because what happens is that
customers put data into this nation and
this case Vickery actually does the
schema validation for you so you're in a
good spot if you use in bakery but if
your destination or your sink does not
do schema validation make sure that you
do that early on in the stage of a
process it helps you with cleaning of
data it helps you with the discovery of
data it helps with the documentation
what's actually in the data all join I
would say eight out of ten of slowness
of any distributed data system that I've
worked with with customers comes from
joining data sets joining data sets that
are big joining data sets that are
skewed and joining data sets that don't
need to be joined at the destination so
what I've found out on what customers
some of my customers do and I'm loved
you guys to do is when you if you think
you need to join common data sets at the
destination at the sink do that joining
during ingest time for example convert
your joints to lookups in this case I'm
using BigTable as a no sequel database
to do a lookup of data as data comes in
and nest that data before data gets sent
to Vickery so now I don't have to do
joining at the destination level it's
not applicable to every use case I'm not
saying you can completely get rid of
join at destination but if you can at
least 30 40 50 percent of your workloads
using nestle that I said you see an
extremely amount of good optimization in
your queries and and whatever you're
doing at the destination so again the
pattern here is convert your joins to
nesting
another thing is pre aggregation another
thing that customers do often is do
aggregation at the destination level so
they let data go in they write group bys
and they do some sort of aggregation if
you can very similar to nesting of data
as data comes in from your desk from
your in just point try to do pre
aggregation before data goes in I've
seen a blog some one of the customers
what they were doing is taking the data
and as data comes in they keep a counter
in the no sequel database and they'll
use that counter to do pre aggregation
of data so for example if they're doing
aggregation on daily basis and let's
just say number of users per day instead
of waiting for that data to get to the
destination and write a group by joint
group by query on top of that data sets
what they do is they say here's a simple
lookup table and BigTable this is my day
and here's a number of counts for that
element in a given day and what they do
is they join they put that data in
BigTable an interesting thing is Big
Creek gives the ability to query
BigTable without moving data so now you
have the ability to join data outside of
your destination there is already joint
now you can write a query that reads
from BigTable directly without actually
applying any group by it simplifies your
architecture simplifies your query and
it actually optimized and gives you much
better performance by far something that
customers are not doing today and I love
to see em view is create a feedback loop
a feedback loop is for you guys to look
at to see what your system is doing and
keep improving it as you see more
workloads and this is one of the best
practice of building s system like a
complex systems complex systems always
apps not a feedback loop so as you're
building your infrastructure as you're
building your analytical infrastructure
use some sort of audit logs for example
bit query gives you an audit log as an
extremely rich set of data set that
tells you what bit Cori has done what
craze has been written
how much bytes scanned what the cost of
that query was so use that feedback loop
for using the audit logs to understand
what queries have you run
for last couple of weeks is it mostly
group-by as a joint do you have a ton of
joints happening and run that report on
weekly basis and once you find these
like repeated group buys and joins take
them apart and see if you can implement
that early on in the stage of a
streaming like for example cloud
functions like I mentioned bring nesting
into the picture bring pre aggregation
at the ingest time into the picture and
run this report every week just to make
sure you're optimizing your
infrastructure and hopefully towards the
end this is the picture you're gonna
have where data comes in from them and
just point you're doing pre aggregation
you're doing joins I'm sorry you're
doing nesting instead of doing join at
the end just points clean data will go
to bigquery or any destination you guys
have and you are running a federated
queries / BigTable where data is already
shown up aggregated and now you have
this end to end at a much lower latency
which much reduce latency and reduce
time to your insight that was me as I
promised quick hopefully I make sense
next I'm gonna bring Robin to the stage
before he speaks
I'm gonna save one fun fact about Robin
I was having dinner with Robin and I
found out not only he's a director of
data engineering their director of data
science and Tapjoy
he's a Multi marathon runner boston
marathon runner ultra marathon runner
and i don't know if you guys know what
ultra marathon run is that's running two
marathons in the same day 52 km/h may be
so Robin on the stage alright thank you
everyone Robin Lee director of data
engineer and data science engineer here
at tip joy so jumping quickly into our
agenda very quickly we're going to talk
about two pieces first one we're going
to talk about I'm VP solution one of the
Rockstar product from Google and then
the second part we're gonna talk about
our journey switching from our
on-premises data center into GCE
specifically we're gonna touch peas are
gonna touch point on how do you how do
we actually run and let's take my
produced work clothes and spark workload
using GCE
so there are going to be
a lot of materials in my session so I
put a lot of the details like
configuration logic details in my slice
I may not necessarily to cover all of
them especially on the second part just
make sure you get a slice later on if
you want to refer back to the logic and
configurations so all right let's move
on
all right so very quickly who we are who
is type 2 what do we do so in shirt tech
joy is advertising network we're sitting
in between you know advertisers and
partners we have our SDK integrated
pretty much into all the top apps within
Android and iOS store and also we're
buying our supplies and demand from open
exchanges so you know in another word we
are you know or annoying videos banners
and messaging pop-ups you have when
using an app the chance is pretty much
is actually from us you know but you
know we try to deliver the right vert
iseman to the right people at right
moment and because we have our own SDKs
we have all the user interaction signals
we need when you when you interact with
an app and when you're interacting with
an advertisement so putting all of these
into some perspective our daily daily
Edition is about 25 terabytes and it is
compressed
if you decompress it is about 100
terabytes per day so our team is very
very vertical starting from the right
hand side we build our own
infrastructure you know including
provisioning servers bring the data in
clean them up make sense of them
training them oh geez you know and serve
them out to for real-time advertisement
predictions at about 500,000 to 700
thousand rpm with the latency less than
20 milliseconds so as you can imagine
our technical stack is very deep and the
part we're going to talk about today is
one MPP and to spark this is a whole
architecture of our current data science
stack but I just want to put a point
which I can attach to day out of the map
so you guys have a reference okay let's
start from brick bakery in 2014 right
you know we're facing increasingly
challenged
how do we scale up our existing NPP
system with very limited resources and
more and viciously how are we going to
do it cheaper I mean not only procure a
cheaper but also as a total cost cheaper
so those are configurations and sorry
very standard ones you know those are
the functions we support it with before
the migration data warehousing you know
EDL's
and we highly we we aggregate them in
using highly irrigated data marts into
stars star schema and the slope
snowflake snowflake schema functions and
supporting all of the reporting system
supporting all analytic hoc operations
and we support all the data features
corporations et cetera so as you can as
you can imagine right those put a lot of
challenges are our small team so storage
compute tightly coupled together on
vertical you know one doesn't really
scale with the other one and we also we
also have all of these technical burdens
on DV DBA and in tests and DevOps tasks
and adding on top of that the cost is
another burden factor including the
licensing cost support cost plus you
know the cost running our our hardware
by ourselves so that's why you know one
big hurry
coming to the pictures quite a
revolutional solutions for us and to be
honest all of these challenges are not
very specific to vertical at a time it's
particular it's I think it's very very
common issue that everybody's facing
back to four or five years ago so let's
take a look take a look at a big career
right when you get into bakery right all
the storage compute or virtually
unlimited if you want to scale up the
issue is pretty much just Google's
problem now and you know I mean in
bigquery there's no more this
projections that projections bigquery
doesn't require and user to put a
projection so in X's our table in order
to perform and no mention there is no
hardware dependencies you don't really
need to worry
about DevOps or DVM in tasks and you
know the terkoz is just gonna be cheaper
I'm gonna touch that specific point in
the later slides so our migration
considerations again very standard was
right we project our cost we benchmark
our workload the diagram you see on the
right hand side was from two from three
four years ago where all the top 15
production crews we were benchmarking at
then this is a stacked bar chart the
right one shows how long it takes to run
it on vertical the blue chart shows how
long a runs in bakery just a disclaimer
this is a back to three years ago these
days I'm sure bigquery will run much
much faster the only thing I want to
highlight on this particular slide is
rewrite remap your data modules and how
do you translate you Curie into bigquery
syntax the reason I want to highlight
these two parts is back to three years
ago the query wasn't supporting the
standard sequel syntax and it doesn't
read I didn't really support the
partition table ie the logical
partitions so that's why we spend a lot
of time I'm sure if we want to go
through the same journey again these
days we don't need to put the same
amount of resources a time on these two
parts so jumping straight into outcomes
scales and cost we're able to twice
scale our data storage just within one
year after we migrated to bakery and we
are able to bring the cost down to 3%
and interestingly interestingly that
factor still holds these days right
putting putting into some context the
hardware cost like that we pay when we
run out vertical still exists exceed the
total amount that we run over our total
workload in bigquery these days and all
the technical benefits we got such as
you know you got this high availability
automatically available to you and all
these disaster recovery capability the
last piece is actually
came into us out of a surprise which
means we're actually sees a lot of less
data friction when we when end-user
trying to utilizing our data and using
data to drive their day-to-day decisions
let me give you some examples so we're
starting to see increasingly number of
account managers sales people product
managers starting to use bakery these
days I think that's only because one
using bigquery is just as using a you
know Gmail interview interface right you
don't really require a user to install a
secret driver or a sequel analyzer by
starting to using that and secondly
sharing data in bigquery is very simple
all the queries can be saved down to a
link and shared and also you can also
run that query city down to a data set
and search share with your counterparts
so all of these combines together we see
increasingly data adoptions within our
organizations so the next few slides
though I'm gonna try to touch some of
the good practices or our practices when
it comes to using bigquery right and
hopefully it'll help you guys so first
of all partitioning tables if you are on
the legacy sequel in bigquery very
intuitively you wanna you want to merge
the less frequently used small
partitions into bagel into bigger ones
and if you are already on the standard
sequel these days what we actually
recommend you to do is you actually
don't expose the raw data to end user
because that's actually a right one
large piece of logical partitions right
and instead you can define the layer of
views for user access and using
something called authorized views to
give different user different access to
different portion of your predictions
alright moving on we absolutely
encourage people to starting to
versioning their schemas and standardize
their schema controls in our practice
for example we don't allow end-user to
change any of the schema definitions
within corporation schemas and instead
if you want to add it add a column or
change a column we ask them to put in a
pull request check in all of their
schemas as a
Wow and there are going to be like
automatic deployment process to order
the table after the per request has been
reviewed and approved specifically we
want we encourage our users to put a
description field right over there right
in the schema file so later on Windows
schema are adapting bigquery you can
actually see the description on the
preview feature this is that's actually
a pretty neat feature in bigquery you
can actually preview the data and
preview all the schema definitions along
with the description field to eat
further encourage of making sense of
data and data options so you know the
next one is about cost control I've been
asked a lot of questions how do you guys
actually do cost control in bigquery
because Vickrey charge you about on a
mount of data moved Pokkiri right the
way how we do it is by putting quota not
onto the men production scheme projects
but on different other projects that
different user groups belongs to for
example our core production projects
sitting in the middle we have different
satellites projects or on it and each
different people each different user
group belongs to the satellite group we
have coder set Amba on those projects
but all of these user can still access
to the production perd projects in that
way they can use their own coder with
from their own projects but still have
have been able to run queries a workload
against the production schemas the left
one right in bigquery section is the
hyper log log function right it stands
for well it is a function used for
cardinality estimation we use a lot
we're absolutely loving it and for
example you can just estimate your
cardinalities for each cycling's and put
it into a sketches if you want to
estimate in the cardinality is across
all of these segments you can merge them
together when it comes to Google's
version of I Prolog blog they actually
improve it in terms of profession
precision and profession and efficiency
they call it hyper lock lock plus right
so I'm gonna take a moment and pause for
a little bit do we
of any google big creep PM sitting in
the audience today no all right I'm
still gonna ask that question how about
exposed to hyper log log functions from
Google via a API or a standardized
library so we can actually produce those
sketches outside of bakery for my use
cases is like I want to starting to
produce carnality as soon as the user
coming in in my streaming process and I
want to dump them later on into bakery
right now where I'm not able to do that
right so that's something I want to ask
Google's p.m. to think about so the next
section right - you know 2 years after
we adopting bakery our on-premises data
center that we built for Hadoop and
spark coming into the live site end of
life cycle so basically people are
facing two options one is to attack
refresh refresh all of these hardware's
and continue resident Colo and then were
you can you know going back to your
cloud platform so we were morning it was
the later one although we have a lot of
fun building our own on-premises data
center but you know there was a lot of
technical burdens you know given the
maturity of the cloud system you know I
think it just makes more sense for the
company our sizes to lean more towards
on from the cost efficiency point of
view so this is a brief history hard
data science computational
infrastructure evolution past so when I
got here in 2011 we'll only have five
node of Hadoop we put it into AWS it was
insanely expensive you cannot believe
how expensive it is back to seven years
ago if you want to run five no tiny
cluster in a cloud so the next year we
decide okay so we want to run our own
Matic bare-metal we use a company called
SoftLayer later on being acquired by IBM
and then in 2014 we decide that say we
want to put a X million dollars buy our
own hardware and put it into a data
center we actually put it a few blocks
away from
from the actually the eight of you as US
East one data center a few blocks away
we turn on them through if with a
direction fiber link and then we our
source or offer you know data center
operations to Eklund acts we use level
three as the network you know we we hire
Maddox loud to do the virtualization
layer for us we do all of these off
sources but we still got all of these
technical burdens like turnaround time
of the smart hands in a cage trying to
reach swap swap a note etc etc so in
2017 we decided to try Google cloud and
those are the considerations again
scales and calls and technicals a very
straightforward intuitive right so
there's no upfront cap up from capital
anymore there is no you don't need to
worry about hardware depreciation
depreciation cost and the piece that
made us to lean more towards Google is
actually our data strategy right we have
running in AWS for our search layer for
a long time but I think it's time for us
to look at a different vendor to prevent
one single vendor lock down and plus we
have been running in victory at the time
for every two over two years we think it
just makes sense for us to put our
Hadoop and spark technology to closer to
our victory to our victory piece and the
last piece is we were running a lot of
machine learning module at that time and
if we think it's the time for us to
start utilizing some of the TPU power
that provided by Google Cloud ml all
right so what specifically why do we run
it elastic MapReduce and spark using GCP
now other cloud vendors they're
basically two ports right first of all
if you want to run elastic MapReduce and
spark cluster one in central point is
you the cloud this should be able to
provision the VMS fast enough right to
minimize the overhead of skeleton in
scale scale up and scaling them so you
know Google always has been known as the
new case around
so a lot of the api's they had they can
design from the ground up
it's actually very efficient compared to
when it comes to the VM launching time
the other reason is the pricing right if
you want to run a good stable spa fleet
in EWS you can you should have at least
beat around 30% on their asking price
you know but if you want to do the same
preemptable instances in Google they
just give you 80% straightaway so that's
something we consider as a pricing
advantages over other piece so how about
this specific elastic usage right so
this is a CPU utilization chart I put it
out from about twenty four hours a day
and if we zoom it in you can actually
see between different times third we're
just utilizing different level of CPU
usage and the framework itself is about
detecting what's the resources just
needed in the queue and trying to scale
up and scaling down accordingly so you
guys probably want to argue there are
just a lot of different vendors on the
market trying to do the same thing right
there are still breaks there is lbs EMR
and there is you know cuckoo Bowl right
all trying to do the same thing why do
we have to try to do it by ourselves
as an in-house solution so the reason is
we are looking some of the specific
features is not available from one
single vendors for example we wanted
cluster to be able to run both Hadoop
and spark within the same cluster we
want it to be able to do dual balancing
and seeking the best pricing within each
of the zone and capacity with each
within the each of the zone and also we
want to run heterogeneous clusters
different different node sizes different
node types and other and there are just
other benefits we try to do some
customizations all of these
functionalities that we require doesn't
really come from one single vendor at
that time so that's why we'd if we
decide to be repair ourselves and you
know more importantly you know how hard
can it be
turns out it's actually not very hard
it actually takes our one developer
three months to pull all of these pieces
together so technically is totally
doable but you know if you want to run
it in an actual cloud production
environment the tuning and
configurations actually takes longer
time so first thing what we did is to
separate the compute and storage that
means our Hadoop and spark cluster
doesn't really resist any permanent data
on the native HDFS within the cluster
itself instead we persist our permanent
data on the cloud storage that doesn't
really mean you cannot store any data on
your local hard drive you can Stu's
store temporary data and provision the
local hard drive for you how to install
cluster right the next piece will be the
MapReduce and spark cluster themselves
doing all the hard work we're using yarn
as our resource manager layer and we use
unbury as open sourced cluster
management to the last piece in there is
the just a general cloud API that
provided Google for spin up a VM shut
down VM so the problem is you know that
piece and this piece
traditionally they don't talk to each
other so all the frameworks trying to
resolve is talking to all of these
different pieces and making sure they
work in the right order
so let's look into different pieces
one by one I already talked about cloud
Ridge cloud storage PC you absolutely
need to separate your storage and
computing order for the two to scale
accordingly and there are just two ways
to structure your Hadoop and spark
cluster one way is you can have your per
cluster per job which means whenever you
spun up a job you spun up a process you
can spun up a cluster and as soon as the
job finishes you share down that cluster
this is actually very clean a easy way
of doing this but we actually see a lot
of overspending and over provision
happens around there for example one of
my data scientists just spun out
requires a 100
Hadoop cost and living in there for like
10 hours nobody knows so another word
don't trust your user right so the way
how we provision our cluster is we have
a finite number of classes and within
each cluster we structured it into two
layers one is what we called persistent
node which is the node runs 2007 which
runs you know the Marsten the name node
resource managers in zookeeper etc
exciter those Kyle like controlling
functions and we also have two to three
what we called based slave node the
reason we have a the slave based slave
node in there to run 24/7 is basically
because a lot of the smartdraft in our
system come and goes really frequently
you you absolutely want to avoid that VM
launching overhead and plus certain my
produced jobs requires to persist a
application binary within the cluster
themselves so those nodes are for those
purposes as well the rest of the layer
will be just the Emperor layer where
we're using spot or preemptable
instances so they can scale up and down
automatically the yum fees there's
really just nothing too much to talk
about it you can you can use muscles if
you want to doesn't really make the hell
of the differences but the only thing I
want to point out is you know this
pending resources section when you query
the yarn jmx metrics this is the class
to wide average remember I said our
cluster require hydrogenous clusters to
run different node sizes different node
type different node types which means we
can support different size of containers
so that means when we run this we're
gonna be be a little bit clever when it
comes to how much resources is pending
in the cube because this is actually a
cluster average not per application or
process average so moving on into the
next two parts are really simple right
I'm very open source cluster management
layer defines what components install on
a cluster within each of the components
what other configurations are this is
actually our pre optional piece I'm not
sure if we have any panel works people
sitting here
if you workload is simple a filled
cluster component-wise is simple you can
ignore this piece but this is a good to
open sourced from homework or in our
cases in our cases we just grab it and
use it in our framework the next one's
cloud API there's just not really too
much to talk about it but one thing I
want to point out is you know try to
abstract your calls to the V to the VM
layer right let's say if I want to
support multi cloud operations in my
clusters right
Google people may not like this but
let's say if I want to propose AWS and
googling within my framework I want to
when I want my framework wants to spun
up a VM the underlying layer needs to be
abstracted to know how to span up a VM
in Google as well as how to span up a VM
in AWS so the next one is just a quick
example of what they called blueprint
definition from unbury which gives you
the definitions in a JSON format for
house group components definition Auto
configurations and hosting
classifications and that rent time
Barbara can get just grab all of these
configuration configurations and
construct a cluster by themselves so
when a resource request coming into the
queue those are the life cycles very
intuitive you know when there's a
request we check whether which resources
available and then we run a job after
job is done we shut down the node very
intuitive what's the hard part on this
diagram the hard part is actually this
piece right when do you try to release a
note that comes to two parts one is you
know how do you actively detect which
node is idle and the second one is how
do you deal with sudden termination of
you note that saying in the middle of a
job one of my underlying node just got
kicked out from the cloud cloud
themselves because of you know supply
constraints
the preemptable instances so I'm going
to touch those two pieces in the later
on slice this is the framework general
structure right I'm not going to go into
too much of details you can always refer
back to the slides the only thing that I
wanna cut out is this particular piece
when you run a hydrogen use cluster of
different note sizes different node
types different note types you
absolutely want to normalize each of
these no types and resources into a
single unit so we can do cross the board
comparison right in arcs for example if
you have a are 4x large instances and if
you are if and if you have and for
actual large instances when it comes to
computational resource and and job
resources how do you compare these two
together right in our cases we normalize
into one single base unit there are four
equivalent to 1.5 as he use the m4
equivalent to you know 1.2 SC use so we
actually borrow this concept from data
breaks the way how they use this
normalization is to charge pricing for
their customer but what we think is you
know that's a cool concept we can use it
to compare resources requirements as
well and those are the actual logic when
it comes to the resource calculations
unfortunately temperature is not an
open-source company so I'm not actually
able to show all of our actual code here
but I use pseudo code to describe the
logic you also probably notice I
strapped out a price feeding part this
is solely for Adria's as for Google you
don't really need to do that it just
gave you 80% discount straight away the
only reason we want to do this in AWS is
because we treat our own module to look
at a histogram of a spot of the price of
as well as all the spikes on the pricing
so try to predict all the pricing at a
given future for a particular instant
type for a given zone all right but that
case doesn't really applies to the GCE
part so the next few slides right it's
about how do you tell you cluster on the
cloud environment
there are a lot of configurations and
considerations that we learned from our
running our elastic MapReduce on the
cloud but I'm not going to go through
into the details the only thing I want
to cut out is this specific piece on the
top how do we identify idle resources
within your cluster right so when you
run or when he it's actually working
different ways in spark and hadoop in
spark executor doesn't really axle and
two other jobs until this job finishes
so it's actually very clean and neat you
can shut down a cluster resources you
know if this the sparked a particular
spark job is finished however when it
comes to my produce a release on the
computational resource or hadoop doesn't
really ring really means to release of
the entire resources for that MapReduce
job for example if you have a MapReduce
some intermediate output and store on
that local hard drive although the job
finished uh sorry although the mapper
finishes a release the computational
resource it doesn't release the local
temporary data that generate generated
which is going to be utilizing in the
later on stage after shuffling in the
reducing stages so if you chop down that
node at this particular moment your
reducer will have to go asking a mapper
again that's my purse gonna must span up
once again to reproduce those data so
you gotta be careful not only checking
the route the computational research
released from a MapReduce job but also
check whether the data are also released
from that particular node alright so for
the last few minutes I absolutely want
to attach the point how to manage
instance lifecycle on a preemptable
instances fleet within GC p right so
this is a about two weeks of data I took
by the end from the end of 2017 each of
the bars here shows you how long each
preemptable instances runs before
the cloud keep them out so we're now
trying to proactively kick them out we
simply launching instances have them
sitting in there and try to see how
lonely it goes right the scales a little
bit difficult to see but the right line
here marks about one hour and if we zoom
in we can actually see the life cycle of
a preemptable instance within Google
cloud are very sparse so within your
framework not only just my produce or
spark whatever the service later you run
with on a cloud environment if you want
to utilize a large amount of pre-emptive
instances like in our case we run 99% of
our workload on preemptable instances
for Hadoop and spark you gotta have some
fell over strategies right to protect
yourself to ease that I've developed
operations so fortunately you know yarn
already handles three out of the four
pieces free right but if you need to do
something for yourself if you own your
job pipeline level right if you wanna
let's say if you're running in Jenkins
oh and or airflow you know always have a
retry strategy so so data your tariffs
people don't need to go in there and we
run a job if they've ever felt because
of the preemptive instance god take away
but even if the above is not very safe
as well let's say in our cases by the
end day we try to run one of the batch
to refresh our modules and refresh other
statistics statistics would use to build
up the module all of these jobs runs
really long about 3-4 hours inevitably
all of the retrial has limits right so
the way how we do this is first of all
at the beginning of this patch we washed
out all the printable instances and then
we filled up the cluster with non
preemptable ones will we hold this
cluster size study by the end of the
batch we worked out all of the non
pre-emptive ones and we wheelied the
cluster to themselves sorry too long do
their own things using preemptable
instances so this is actually a very
clean and a neat way of doing this
guarantee to work the downsides of this
when you used non-printable instances
you gotta pay like 8 times more
expensive than the preemptable you was
so at the beginning of our adoption into
GCP this is the right this is actually
the way in production but these days is
not right these days we do a hack if
you're interested how do we do that for
pre-emptive instance feel free to
contact me because that hackers is
relies on analyzing Google's behavior of
its own data so I don't think I should
be able to disclose on a public but pin
me if you have that questions in mind
after the work so I know there's a lot
of again I know there's a lot of
materials I went through for specific
logic and configurations refer back to
my slides if you want to that marks the
end of my session and now we'll compare
the pervious back so we take questions
thank you
[Music]